okay now this we have to discuss
the newest idea for trump to crowbar his
way back into power
is that he could run for a seat in the
house of representatives in 2022
and then if he wins he could try to
become the speaker of the house of
representatives and then a speaker of
the house he could then impeach
joe biden this is something that wayne
allen root asked donald trump about on
his radio show late last week
wayne allen root has been a guest on
this show a bunch of times
and it's been pretty wacky every time
you can check that out
on our youtube channel if you're
interested and trump seemed interested
in this
uh that that it was really an idea worth
considering take a look at this video
why not instead of just waiting for 2024
and i'm hoping you run
in 2024 but why not why not run in 2022
for the united states congress a house
seat in florida
win big lead us to a dramatic landslide
victory taking the house
by 50 seats and then you become the
speaker of the house
lead the impeachment of biden and start
criminal investigations against biden
you'll wipe him out for his last two
years and then you'll be president
do it you know it's very interesting
it's so interesting
you'll be a folk hero and people have
said people have said run for the senate
okay run for the senate but you know
what your idea might be bad it's very
interesting
now this is actually something that
steve bannon has floated before the idea
of trump
running for congress or maybe even
senate but congress
and then figuring out okay now what what
can we do about joe biden bannon spoke
to the
boston republicans back in february and
said trump could run for the house quote
we totally get rid of nancy pelosi and
the first
act of president trump as speaker will
be to impeach
joe biden for his illegitimate
activities
of stealing the presidency so bannon's
already been thinking
along these lines now the funniest part
about this i have to tell you
is that trump could run for speaker of
the house
without being a member of congress i
know this might sound
strange but our friend of the show bill
share pointed this out tweeting quote
why are republicans telling trump he
should run for the house to become
speaker
you don't have to be a house member to
be speaker it's a whole lot easier to
just demand to be speaker the house
republican party
would cancel mccarthy faster than the
dixie chicks
now this is true it's true that you
don't
have to be a member of the house to be
speaker of the house
but tradition does play a big role bill
share is technically right the speaker
of the house in the united states
is not legally required to be an elected
member of the house of representatives
but if you look at
the articles of the confederation which
predate the constitution
it does say that the congress of the
united states has the power
to quote appoint one of their number to
preside
so it doesn't have to be that way just
i could be speaker of the house you
could be speaker of the house without
being a member if the members of the
house
do select you but needless to say
let's not give donald trump this idea i
don't actually
expect donald trump to run for the house
if he did
it's certainly plausible that if he won
and republicans took the house in 2022
you could maybe see republicans choose
donald trump
as speaker of the house but the funniest
thing for me
there's two really funny things about
this for me one
if trump hated being president because
everybody kept
asking him to do stuff when he just
wanted to watch tv
he would despise being a member of the
house you actually
sort of have to do some more stuff
than as president if you're a member of
the house you're expected to show up in
your district and do some constituent
work although
you know maybe if it's trump he wouldn't
be expected to do that that's number one
that's funny
but then the really funny thing is this
idea
conflicts with trump being back in power
in august
in other words why would trump run for
house of representatives
in november of 2022 if he's going to be
president again
in august of 2021 as is now being widely
reported that he believes
the one way that this could backfire
is if trump decides to run for a house
seat especially on a plan of becoming
house speaker
and it does seem to me that
it could backfire in that if trump's
running for the house i think democrats
get really active we've been talking
about who is going to be able to get the
vote out in the upcoming 2022 midterms
and in general it's not good for the
party that takes over the white house
partially
because they are sort of happy and
satisfied that they've taken over the
white house two years later they tend to
stay home
more than the opposite party so that
favors republicans
if trump's running for the house i think
it reinvigorates democrats and democrats
come out
and vote vote vote in 2022 in a way that
would probably not be so good for
republicans that's just my thought
let me know what you think and tell me
if you agree that trump would absolutely
hate being a member of the house
during the pandemic and even at this
point i try to avoid
physically visiting a doctor's office
unless i really have to and that's why
i love our sponsor steady md primary
care
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician who's a
good fit for you
you have a one hour virtual appointment
and you start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone and video chat and unlike
other services
this isn't some random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
can give you the personal attention you
deserve
they can help you with anything your
primary care doctor
normally would healthy diet managing
conditions weight loss sleep
depression anxiety you don't need
insurance it's just
99 a month with absolutely no other fees
or co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
go to steadymd.com pacman there's no
risk
no long-term commitment the link is
right underneath this video